Dustin and Weston,
congratulations.
You fellas have made it to
the third and final round
of this competition.
Now, when you came here, we
had you make Japanese bushcraft
knives called natas.
Now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history.
You ready to see what it is?
BOTH: Yes.
All right, that weapon is--
the Zulu war axe.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck.
[music playing]
WESTON: Spent a
little bit of time
in South Africa, so I've seen
some small versions of this.
I'm planning on doing a
Damascus exterior on both sides.
And then I'm going to leave
a 80CRV2 internal core.
First weld on the
billet, it looks
like it's going really well.
It's time to draw
the billet out.
I'll cut it and reforge it.
That should give me
57 layers of Damascus.
I'm going to twist that to
make a really cool pattern.
Now it's time to stack it with
80CRV2 so that if something
happens with one of my
welds, the axe still
has a good strong solid core.
It was a good day of forging.
I'll have to definitely
step it up tomorrow
to get back into it.
All right, that was fun.
[music playing]
DUSTIN: So my goals for today
are to get the axe head roughly
shaped, hopefully get the tang
drawn out to where I like it,
and get bevels hammered in.
I start by forging out
the top of the axe.
As I'm drilling it out,
I'm hammering bevels in.
Gotten about an
inch and a half.
2 and 1/2 more to go.
DUSTIN: I've got the Zulu axe
to where I would like it to be.
It's pretty well shaped.
And now it's time to address
the oddly placed tang.
Unfortunately, my opening is
just not big enough to allow
me to go back and forth.
So I've got to cut the whole
front of the forge out.
And now, we have a nice big
opening to come straight in.
The length of my tang is the
biggest obstacle right now.
It's too skinny
as well as short.
It's something I want to tackle
first thing in the morning,
because if I can't
fix it, I want
to start over as
soon as possible
rather than wasting any time.
[music playing]
WESTON: It's the
morning of day two.
I'm working on the billet.
Game plan is to split it and
start forging out the tang.
I've noticed that
there's a couple cracks.
I'm going to grind down
through those areas
and see if they grind out as I
get closer to my final shape.
My plan for getting
the tang attached,
I'm going to cut a little
notch to the length of my tang.
So we'll heat it up, chisel
down, push that out, and draw
out our tang, finish our blade.
WESTON: Now it's just drawing
it out to length to make sure
I meet parameters.
Going into the clinch, I'm
feeling a little nervous.
Those cracks in the blade
that I'd seen earlier,
I think I've got
them ground down.
I think we dodged a
bullet on this one.
I think it's
looking really good.
DUSTIN: So I start today off
with a problem with my tang.
My tang is just way too
skinny as well as short.
I cut two pieces of
high carbon steel,
fit them up next to my tang.
I weld them in to make
it wider and longer.
But with so much going
right, eventually
something's going to go wrong.
My breaker blew.
I'll be back in one second.
DUSTIN: I really hope this
isn't a reoccurring issue today.
I have a lot of work to do
when I build my quench tank,
and there's a lot of
welding involved to do so.
My quench tank is going
to be like a trough style.
I'm going to
horizontally quench it.
So I'm getting ready to
weld, and I'm thinking,
it's going to be fine.
As soon as it tries to start,
poof, my breaker goes out.
[bleep]
DUSTIN: So back and
forth and back and forth.
So, many, many
trips to the breaker
later, I have a
finished quench tank.
I feel good now.
I'm happy.
DUSTIN: What a pain in
the ass that was, man.
Now I've got to get it quenched.
So I go into the
oil, and I've got
this thing quenched straight.
It skates like glass,
solid as an oak.
I couldn't be happier.
WESTON: Top of day four.
My game plan for today is put
the final edge on the blade
and then try to get the
wood section of this
build figured out.
I've got a section
of Osage orange
that I've been working on,
and I've got another section
of African ebony.
I'd really like
to use the ebony.
I think the black would work
great with the Damascus.
The best way to
tell if this handle
will hold up to
the judges' testing
is to test it here first.
[record scratch]
Well.
WESTON: Just what you
don't want to have
happen to your expensive
beautiful piece of ebony.
But better here than there.
Now it's back to the
Osage orange handle.
Before I do the final glue-up
and get my blade mounted
to the axe handle, I want
to get the final edge
put on the blade.
The convex grind I put on this
should have enough backing
behind it to keep the edge
from having any damage
if it hits wood or bone.
It's looking sharp.
WESTON: Time's up, and there's
nothing else I can do to it.
I feel like it's
going to perform well.
It should be able to
handle all the tests.
Liking it.
It's looking good.
DUSTIN: The plans for today
are to do some more grinding
on my axe head, and I've
got to do a little bit
more work to my handle.
I'm going to spend a little time
on the grinder cleaning it up,
getting it to where
I want it to be.
Now the blade is 90% done
without an edge on it.
It's time to get
back to my handle.
So now I'm going to do some
burn work on this handle.
I've never done it
before, so I hope
it really makes the grain pop.
It definitely came
out really nice.
DUSTIN: So now to
finish the blade,
I'm going to do an acid edge.
I'm really stoked right now.
It's just better than
I could have imagined.
DUSTIN: So I put a convex
edge on it, something
that can withstand
smashing, but can
also be sharp enough to slice.
Awesome.
Your Zulu war axes
look quite scary.
But it's time to find out
what kind of lethal damage
they can do.
To find it out, I
will take your weapon,
deliver some chops and
slashes on this boar carcass.
Dustin, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
Knew it.
Well done, sir.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Dustin, let's
talk about your Zulu war axe.
It's quite surprising
that something
this light with
not a lot of metal
can cut deep into
this boar carcass.
Your blade stayed true.
The handle construction
is ovoid enough
to where even though it tapers,
I have a very good feel for it.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Weston, your turn.
So you ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Weston, let's talk
about your Zulu war axe here.
What I find interesting here is
that the design of this blade,
there's a sweet spot in here
with a little bit of weight.
So that first swing
alone cut in very deep.
There are no glints
or rolls on it.
The handle construction
is ovoid enough
to where I get a good grip and
I can get a good feel on it.
And more importantly,
sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test--
the ammo box chop.
I'm going to test the strength
and durability of your axes
by smashing them into
these ammo boxes.
Remember, this test
is all about what
those boxes do to your axes
and not the other way around.
Dustin, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
[metal clangs]
[sighs] [clicks tongue] Damn it.
Well, Dustin, we've got
an obvious issue here.
Now, I'm looking at
your grain in here.
It's beautiful.
It's nice and velvety tight.
But right here, there's a little
dark spot which was a crack.
It happened right where the join
of your tang and your blade is.
And that little crack
is a stress riser,
and it leads to big failure.
Sure.
All right, Dustin,
your blade has
broke on the third strike
against these ammo boxes
in our strength test.
Now, that doesn't mean that
you're out of this competition.
Your competitor still has
to endure the same rigors.
Weston, that means
that your blade
must survive three strikes
against these ammo boxes.
And if it does, you'll be
the new "Forged in Fire"
champion taking home
that check for 10 grand.
You guys ready for this?
- Let's do it.
All right, Ben.
All right, Weston,
how are you feeling?
Nervous.
[music playing]
Good job.
Thanks.
Well, Weston, it held up.
Nice job.
This is a nice light axe.
A lot of fun to swing.
With every swing, I could feel
the reverberation, just it kind
of jiggling in my hands.
It was singing.
Really well done.
Thank you.
Weston, congratulations.
Your blade held up.
Dustin, that means that your
blade doesn't make the cut.
I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands,
shake your competitor's hand,
and then exit the forge.
Great job, man.
Thank you, sir.
DUSTIN: I'm pretty bummed out.
I really wanted to
win this whole thing.
Weston, congratulations, bud.
Thank you.
Good job.
DUSTIN: But this has
been one of the greatest
experiences of my life.
This is not the result I wanted.
But at the end of the day, I'm
here, I'm alive, I'm healthy,
so I'm happy.
Weston, congratulations.
You made a beautiful
Zulu war axe,
and that makes you the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
That's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Come forward and shake
our hands, my friend.
WESTON: I am the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and I feel elated.
I came here to
prove that I could
compete with some
incredibly talented smiths,
and I came out on top.
It's been a blast.
[music playing]